who's your best guy that you'd like to  see perform  i mean it's it's hard not to say conor  mcgregor i mean conor mcgregor comes out  and puts on a show  the world goes crazy the whole world is  buzzing when that's  gonna come back and he's gonna knock  this guy out they they're gonna they're  gonna fight all the time i mean is that  all time all the guys you had yeah it  has to be  yeah yeah i like kind of yeah he's a  showman  yeah he's a showman yeah there's people  coming to see the show  he bring the noise uh in and out man it  sure does  man conor mcgregor and the gate and the  pay-per-view  yeah pay-per-view when it comes to that  top of the food chain  and some of this liquor too  [Music]  you